peut-être moins connu et moins visités
que chenonceau est celle rideau le
château du c'est pourtant séduit
stéphane bern pour le tournage de son
émission le monument préféré des
français avec ses 105 mille visiteurs
annuels le château et dans la famille
ben la case depuis 1850 un héritage que
le duc casimir septième du nom fait
partager aux touristes et aux enfants
car le château un secret château du
château de la belle au bois dormant
parce qu'il a inspiré charles perrault
il y as d'élève de charles perrault en
comptant son émerveillement devant reus
et lors des visites qui est rendu au
marquis de valentine est le propriétaire
de l'époque et il raconte qu'il a été
inspiré par ses toits pointus cette
pierre blanche la grande forêt sur
laquelle est adossé le château d'eau et
pour nos jeunes amis visiteurs nos
petits amis visiteurs tout petit nous
avons mis en place des scènes de la lame
du conte de la belle au bois dormant qui
émerveille les enfants naître dans un
château de conte de fées c'est ce qui
est arrivé à casimir de mme lacasse
cet avocat parisien a tout donné pour
restaurer ardoise après ardoise pierre
après pierre le château une passion
coûteuse mais aussi l'histoire d'une vie
qu'il partage au quotidien avec les
touristes
je pense que ça a beaucoup joué dans le
choix de stéphane bern effectivement un
monument finalement pas tellement connu
et est habitée et habiter en osmose avec
les visiteurs n'y a pas une partie
vraiment séparé oublier notre salle à
manger par exemple ici cette salle à
manger est ouverte au public
et lorsque nous sommes l'hiver en
famille belle nous l'utilisons telle
qu'elle est là c'est un des plus beaux
châteaux du val de loire et je pense
qu'effectivement tout le monde devrait
voter pour pour ce château en
l'occurrence cette région parce que non
c'est magnifique
alors le château de la belle au bois
dormant sera-t-il le monument préféré
des français
réponse pour les journées du patrimoine